we are in the midst of a culture war
although it started in the universities
particularly in france
through the open portal of the damnable
yale
and then into the rest of the institutes
of higher education
it is not only the faculty and
administrators of our colleges and
universities who are at fault
those charged with the privilege and
responsibility of running the corporate
world are lining up to kowtow at the d i
e alter diversity inclusivity and equity
at a rate that exceeds
and with a cowardice comparable to that
characterizing the most contemptible of
pencil-necked academics
i had hoped that ceos in particular evil
capitalists all
would reject this nonsense this idiot
post-modernism with its denial of any
objective world divine or material this
appalling and murderous marxist wolfery
in sheep's clothing but it turns out
that the left's ability to weaponize
guilt and the contempt that far too many
in the business world have for ideas
have proved an unstoppable combination
perhaps i should have seen this coming
part of what doomed the benighted
universities
was a thoughtless corporatism
the introduction of managerial speak
among the administrators too many of
whom were failed and therefore
demoralized lecturers and researchers
turning in desperation
to ape the business world
when all academics worth their salt
so to speak at least have the spine to
have some contempt for their competitors
on the public status front deserved as
it is in some ways or not
and i knew too from extensive experience
talking to corporate types that the
human resources departments were
resentful and corrupt and ill-informed
and desperate for power at any cost
and even worse than the dreadful hr
die combination perhaps
if that is even possible is the new
corporate and government craze for
environment social and governance dicta
so-called esgs
as every idiot fad needs an oh so in the
know acronym
as one set of corporate consulting
half-wits and moral postures put it
quote investors are increasingly
applying these non-financial factors as
part of their analysis process to
identify material risks and growth
opportunities
esg metrics are not commonly part of
mandatory financial reporting though
companies are increasingly making
disclosures in their annual report
or in a standalone
sustainability report
non-financial factors
applied to identify material risks
stand-alone sustainability reports
all this smacks of central planning
not to mention a low
shallow
self-justifying moralizing which can and
does in no wise stand in for genuine
ethical action
those planet-saving sustainability goals
can simply and finally not be instituted
from the top down particularly not when
they will be both formulated and
enforced by people
who are very interested in looking good
but very short on experience ability and
wisdom
ceos
how can you not see
oh yes there's that contempt for ideas
again there's that guilty pandering to
the utopian leftist mob
the die mandates and esg disclosures and
the massive administrative bureaucracy
that thrives on such pseudo work
is precisely equivalent
to the worst sort
of fifth column
you ceos
are elevating the least competent people
in your corporations
that's you
human resources personnel
to the highest positions of decision
making and company planning
turning over your hiring decisions to
those deluded enough to think that
diversity
is a substitute for ability
and to believe that equity
merely means equality of opportunity
what does it mean
how about you take the time to find out
a hint
it means
equality of outcome
a principle utterly and absolutely
antithetical
to every free market principle ever
established
and a doctrine as opposed to the
operations of the capitalist world as
anything conceivable produced
by the dread imagination
of the hypothetical bastard child of
karl marx and michelle foucault
and if you can't see this
or worse
won't
then you are either too ignorant to be
doing what you are doing
or willfully blind and precisely the
manner that will usher in the darkest of
days you can possibly imagine
and what of
esg
principles
do i know of what i speak
well throughout 2010 and 2011 i worked
with the sole canadian contingent on the
un's 2012 original sustainability plan
document resilient people resilient
planet a future worth choosing and i
learned something about how such
sausages were made
although the so-called high-level panel
charged with this overwhelming and tower
of babylisque task was hypothetically
made up of the typical stellar
luminaries ex-presidents and prime
ministers and their ilk in reality the
task of actually writing the paper and
therefore thinking through the details
where the devil hides
was typically shunted down the hierarchy
of authority
until it landed on the desk of someone
who had the interest time and
presumption to devote some real effort
to the task
someone like me
i say this without cynicism
ex-presidents etc have calendars that
are fully booked often months or even
years in advance and simply do not have
the time resources or often the ability
to sit down and think through
write
and edit the vast research proposal
because that's what the un report really
was
that makes up
a plan
for the planet
and who does who's an expert in
planetary sustainability
no one
it's too complicated
and that's why we have a decentralized
free market
economy oh captains of industry
goals
reduced without much thought to a still
unwieldy 17.
by what mechanism by whose choice
with what evidence that such planning is
desirable to say nothing of possible or
more likely counterproductive in an
absolute sense
we have a decentralized free market
economy so that the invisible hand
which is actually a gigantic distributed
computational system
calculating adaptation to the
transforming horizon of the future
so that the invisible hand the free
choice of product and occupation
characterizing billions of people
can guide us as unerringly and selfishly
thank god for that as possible into the
future
and this simply cannot be replaced by
the utopian handwaving of centralist
globalist planners
even if they are blessed with the
charisma and brilliance of that
consummate conference organizer klaus
schwab
the computations of the decentralized
free market system
guided as it must be by a necessary
minimum of political constitutions and
international treaties simply cannot be
replaced by brute force top-down
machination no matter how
well-intentioned
remember what the road to hell is paved
with
we tried that
with the bloody five-year plans of
stalin and mao
remember how that turned out
and
if you think the comparison is
ridiculous
then just start thinking about the 150
million people who will be hungry later
this year
when the first results of the decision
to scuttle the energy industry in the
name of planetary survival
roll out
and just give some consideration to the
fact that the idiot environmental
utopian faux moralizers have proved
themselves in the last few years
entirely willing to sacrifice today's
actual poor
to the thriving hypothetical poor who
will if we haven't ethically depopulated
ourselves entirely in the next few
decades
grace the planet with their sustainable
low carbon footprint in the lower your
expectations future we are all guiltily
planning
and just remember who enabled an
emboldened putin
and pray that wasn't a fatal mistake
as it probably was
and so ceos you need to shed your guilt
you are
evil capitalists
just as charged you've worked your whole
life to be precisely that
are you going to capitulate now in the
face of social criticism and disavow
everything you have done
instead you should wear that badge
proudly evil capitalist
recognizing explicitly
that there is simply no better
alternative
although capitalism produces inequality
and inequality when unchecked poses a
real danger to social stability
every economic system ever created by
man
does the same
and often more egregiously
but not every system produces wealth
in fact
none have
except free market capitalism
which has
in recent decades
lifted an
unprecedented number of people
not least in putatively communist china
out of the absolute poverty that has
been the rigid and certain destiny of
everyone for the entire span of human
history
capitalism indeed produces inequality
but it also remediates dire privation
for the first time in the entire painful
temporal span comprising life here on
earth
everyone has enough to eat
except when political machination
interferes and malevolence gains the
upper hand
obesity is now a bigger problem than
starvation
but not for long if the die enthusiasts
and the esg moralists and centralizers
have their way
why are you kowtowing to those who
despise your companies
and your accomplishments
perhaps
it's genuine guilt
the conscientious drivers
who often come to occupy positions of
authority in conservative corporate
institutions
are dutiful industrious orderly
and hardworking this also makes them
guilt-prone
and when such people look at their lives
and their let's say demographic
characteristics white middle or upper
class disproportionately male and
english-speaking they feel and rightly
so
that some of their so-called privilege
and everyone who uses that word is the
mortal enemy of c-suite executives
was and is in fact
undeserved
all of us in the western world were in a
sense fortunate to be born here and now
when these vast educational resources
and realms of computational power are
available to us when we will never have
to ask will we have enough to eat or
will we have somewhere to rest our heads
and some of that is
undeserved
none of us alive
built the amazing cities roadways or
industrial machinery that has brought
about our wealth all of us alive are the
beneficiaries of the hard work of our
ancestors
and worse have the temerity to thrive
on the blood-soaked lands of plantation
and imperialism and atrocity
that make up the states provinces and
countries that house
shelter and protect us
and so
we must atone
and rightly so
but we cannot and must not do this by
bending a knee to the rabid centralizers
and fulminating ignorant and resentful
who shake a moralizing fist in the air
and object so loudly
anyone with more money than me is an
oppressor
that is a very bad pathway
that is the true road to a future that
no one except the devil himself wants
so
if you are a ceo and you are wringing
your hands about the planet
and you wake up at three in the morning
upgrading yourself for your shenanigans
on the moral front your untrammeled and
narrowly self-serving greed in the
service of your hedonism and narcissism
then do what you must most truly do
to become a better person
justify your money and your unparalleled
opportunities by becoming a shining
light in the darkness
it is said
for unto whomsoever much is given
of him shall be much required
and to whom men have committed much
of him
they will ask the more
what does this mean
it means as the rest of the sermon on
the mount insists that the way to pay
for privilege
is by doing the good that is
commensurate with that privilege and
this is the way out of the guilt ceos
that makes you such easy targets for the
demented and satanic moralizing of the
accuser
are you wealthy
be better
do so much good with your money and your
other privileges that when the mob comes
you can say
i have devoted myself truly to the
highest good and can stand innocent
before you and my own conscience
and you
mobsters
have you looked to your own redemption
have you borne the responsibility of
your own unexamined privilege you who
dwell equally in the exploitation and
atrocity of the so-called imperialist
west
who exactly are you to call me and my
talent and privilege out in the name of
god
i cannot help but think in closing
that there is an appalling greed in all
this d i e and esg posturing
one of the things i found most
intolerable about the ivy league
environment
was the fostered narcissism of the
students
all who gain entry to yale or harvard or
princeton or stanford or even to the
university of toronto where i lectured
for 20 years
are already part of the elite
by any standards historical and present
but
they are enticed
as an easy escape from their privilege
let's say
into identifying with the oppressed
agitating
in principle
on their behalf and atoning for their
good fortune
purchased at the cost in no small part
of the atrocity of the past
with the reflexive and thoughtless
activism whose promotion has come to
substitute for genuine apprenticeship
and education
this means that the new elite the
youthful privileged
get to have their cake and eat it too
they have all the stature and
opportunity bestowed upon them and
available to them as a consequence of
their university affiliation and the
hard work and ability that was required
to open those doors
and then also
all the moral high ground that accrues
to the unjustly oppressed
that
is just
too much
that is just asking
too much to be privileged and victimized
simultaneously
just as it's too much for university
professors to ask
and even more so as it's too much for
ceos and other denizens of the executive
suite to request
so
stop saving the world with the
centralizers globalists narcissists and
eternal builders of the tower of babel
stand forth instead as i said
as proudly evil capitalists
do your fiduciary duty
provide your customers and clients with
what they need and want
and let the great invisible hand that
immense computational device
play its necessary role
make your enterprise productive and
profitable make yourself generous
and abide by the dictates of your
conscience
do enough
signal good
so that your great wealth rests
lightly
on your shoulders
this is a more difficult task take note
than generating that wealth itself
put the human resources die personnel
back in their place
stop hosting faux democratic town halls
since when do you care what the stock
boys think
in a few decades if they have the
fortitude ability and industriousness
they will be sitting in your hard one
place
and making the decisions that you are
currently charged with making
did you not earn that right
then why forego it under moral pressure
and if the answer is guilty conscience
then
straighten yourself out get your
oppressive super-ego under control
or
stop doing those possibly terrible and
unworthy things that make you guilty
when the mob knocks at your door
stop making obeisance
to the alphabet brigade
stop educating your customers remember
them as to what political opinions are
acceptable
stop with the full communist pretense
unless you want to go there
and if you do
think again sunshine
stop pretending that there are a hundred
and fifty different genders
and that it is your job to be so
compassionate toward all narcissistic
outsiders
that you tempt children into ill-advised
and terribly destructive surgery
make the following pledge
i will rename human resources
personnel
as those who performed that role were
known in the so sensible 1950s
i will dispense forthwith with all the
diversity inclusivity and equity
consultants flotsam and jetsam
those who have allowed themselves to be
possessed by that ideology
are not your friends
and if you are consorting with them to
look good for reasons of greed and
vanity
then
think again
once again
because the system of ideas that
animates the woke moralists is dead set
and in the most serious manner against
you and everything you stand for
particularly when you are being
genuinely
good
more pledge
i will stop flirting with the grandiose
esg mavens
isn't saving your company enough
do you really have to so casually and
thoughtlessly save the world to
have some humility
and stay in your already plenty large
wheelhouse
and more
on the pledge front
i will pay some more attention to the
realm of philosophical even theological
ideas
as i said
and as so many are insisting we are in a
conceptual war ceos and it goes all the
way
to the bottom
what side do you want to be on when the
chips are down
don't be thinking you can play both
sides against the middle
the deepest chasms of hell are reserved
for those who play that game
don't be thinking either
that you can cheaply escape from the
burdens of your responsibility with all
that money and so-called power that you
can pull the wall over the eyes of the
human resources moralists
that acquiescing to their insane demands
will solve any problems whatsoever
or
that you will not be called upon
directly to account for your privilege
in the most real of senses
pledge further
i will stop manipulating the psyches of
my employees i will stop educating them
politically
and i will stop anyone in my company
from ever doing so
political education
is the job of kgb commissars
not of corporate executives
ceos
i implore you
start standing up
for what you are
and what you do
if your company is genuine
if it is addressing the true needs and
wants of genuine customers if the people
you serve are being informed honestly by
the agents of your company about the
services you offer
and if you deliver what you are paid to
deliver
then there is nothing to feel guilty for
quite the contrary
and if there is
because something shady is going on
then stop inhabiting the dark places and
the shade
and do well enough
so that your conscience to say it again
is clear
perhaps you should at least be
on your own side